stranger things star Millie Bobby Brown  gushes over the hit Netflix shows two  Golden Globe nominations it's incredible  [Music]  the 12 year old actress spoke with et on  the red carpet at UNICEF's 70th  anniversary event in New York City on  Monday where she was clearly ecstatic  over the exciting news first I was like  don't be silly  yes no it's true and I'm very excited  and the Deaf Brothers completely  deserved it they worked very hard and  our cast and crew and obviously Winona  and congrats to her because she worked  very very hard we all did and so I'm  very excited to attend and yes she also  teased the unsung ball she might be  wearing to the award show next month you  never know with me I can turn up in a  unicorn onesie or this so I'm very  excited yeah and revealed her upcoming  plans for the holidays so going back to  England because I need to go see my  family  [Music]